le reportage n'a pas encore commencé la
caméra n'est pas encore installée que
l'acteur déjà se confie un peu comme
s'il parlait avec ses pieds je suis
comédien metteur en scène et voilà là je
présente deux spectacles au théâtre aimé
césaire de fort de france à un théâtre
que j'affectionne particulièrement
puisque j'ai commencé en fait j'ai joué
de danse théâtre quand j'étais au lycée
le théâtre aimé césaire c'est un peu
comme chez lui
il court il va il vient se couche à van
roekeghem
tout ça pour raconter l'histoire d'un
personnage qui est censé être mort et
qui revisite de sa vie je pensais
qu'être père serait une expérience - - -
embarrassante preto
j'ai pensé qu'il valait mieux te laisser
faire un thé disent que rien de ce que
je pourrais apporter ne voudrait ce que
tu as prendrait par toi même tu as dû te
sentir bien seul au monde ça le monde
c'est le titre de sa pièce jouée ici
mardi et mercredi en tant qu'acteur mais
pour la deuxième
programmée ce vendredi et samedi nelson
rafale intervient cette fois comme
metteur en scène ça s'appelle poussière
et c'est un conte initiatique ça raconte
l'histoire d'une jeune fille qui quitte
le moulin familial qui quitte l'endroit
où elle vit avec sa famille qui dit pour
moi c'est lille puisque je suis
d'origine martiniquaise et que je suis
parti à un moment vivre à paris pour
travailler et c est donc l est elle vit
dans ce moulin familial avec son père et
puis avec simon sont meilleurs amis
entre guillemets et un moment elle a
envie de partir elle a envie de
découvrir le monde elle a envie de
découvrir un ailleurs de voyager et le
spectacle raconte toutes les épreuves
qu'elle va devoir affronter pour pouvoir
partir sur scène ou en coulisses
nelson raphaël sait mieux que personne
cette vérité de sénèque la vie est une
pièce de théâtre
ce qui compte ce n'est pas qu'elle soit
longue mais qu'elle soit bien joué